you are no stranger to working out at
your house neither am i so i hope you're
ready for this one uh and i know that
i'm pretty sure neither of us do it this
way okay law and order star christopher
maloney has revealed when he's
exercising at home that he prefers to go
nude
okay
well
uh you heard that right
nude i there's so many things in my head
right now and i'm picturing and
oh
there's so many things could get damaged
man speaking with people magazine at the
nbc uh universal upfronts chris admits i
work out naked it's my gym and i don't
black out the window and i'm okay with
that my wife is not
i've read that very slowly because your
neighbors
i mean yeah i mean
there's there's other people anyways uh
when we spoke with chris on the red
carpet we had to ask about that now
viral video of himself doing the split
fun set which as it turns out was
rebuttal to a quote hit piece about his
ego take a look and we'll see you next
time
this photo let's go i mean went viral
the photo of you doing the split tell me
about that
um
all it was was a reaction to
a hit piece
discussing my oversized ego on the set
and how i stretch and do clapping
push-ups and
think of myself as the cat's meow so i
thought that was going to be my response
and i enlisted the the crew
to help me what was the determined was
it zaddy what does that mean
one of the articles yeah yeah uh i know
an older gentleman who is
still
i don't know
i don't know whether
i got hot i guess
yeah
well at least that's how i took it